ein junger für meine damen und herren
und willkommen zum adventskalender an
box legen teil 2 die edition natürlich
habe ich es nicht geschafft den zweiten
teil gleich am nächsten tag aufzunehmen
denn wer schafft ist mit einem kater ok
karte an die kötter bier
ich lag das ganze wochenende flach leute
ich bin ehrlich mit euch ab 25 ist das
leben auch einfach nicht mehr so leicht
besonders mit alkohol das zeug das
nervengift es macht dich fertig und
deswegen trägt mir am montag weiter
dieser adventskalender packen menschen
mit behinderungen ein also in
behindertenwerkstätten was ich mega cool
findet also box land großen respekt an
dich das ist klassik frei und sogar mit
sozialen engagement
das freut mich sehr und jetzt probieren
wir san miguel das gab es auch auf
mallorca miguel ist ein spanisches bier
das schmeckt eigentlich sehr gut
[Musik]
wie gleich wieder in diesem modus
verfalle also leute das glas ist nicht
so sauber wie ich es mir weil sie nie
was da passiert ist die farbe ist sehr
dunkel golde der luft ist sehr schwierig
sein die ganz einfach ein gutes bier
besser international
ja ich bin anderes platz wir sollen ja
unseren qualitätsstandard hier auch ein
bisschen bier nummer 14
chinesisches bier seit 1903 also bei uns
in deutschland durch ihr schon länger
wir gemacht
es ist sehr hell hat sehr viel sprudel
irgendwie nicht nach
es riecht nach nichts kult ist 7 und
natürlich ist er reist ich bin mir nicht
so sicher aber doch es schmeckt voll gut
es schmeckt irgendwie anders ich weiß
jetzt am reis liegt er da drin ist aber
es schmeckt auf jeden fall einfach nach
diesem adventskalender sagen dass ich
schon bier aus fast jedem land probierte
15 kulmbacher hollenbacher edel herbst
legendäres grünbacher p gebraucht nach
dem bayerischen reinheitsgebot von 1516
1516 wie lange gibt es den buchdruck die
erfindung des modernen buchdruck es geht
auf den mainzer goldschmied johannes
gutenberg zurück der durch die
verwendung von beweglichen metallenen
lettern ab 1450 ein als manufaktur
betriebenes drucksystem einführte und
meine kunden wache leute hier riecht
sehr gut liegt sehr reich wird man sich
sein
blumig süß frisch ich finde das so krass
dass man vom geruch her irgendwie nie
sagen kann
schmecken wird es schmeckt wirklich so
als ob bis 1516 auch so geschmeckt hätte
nur als schnecken kopfschmerz bier
nummer 16
ironie noch ein italienisches bias ist
jetzt schon das vierte italienische
video das wir haben drei konzessionen
5,1 lob wir haben ihn gewinnen ausmacht
kaum schauen und im glas wie das gerade
echt aussieht weiß man riecht ganz
schüchtern
wir wissen aber das ist halt nix mit den
geschmack aus bei mir ist es so schwer
zu entscheiden ob es ein gut schmeckt
oder nicht ja so viel wie perlet tipp
wenn ihr alkohol trinkt immer dazwischen
drängen das sollte wohl dieser
bildungsauftrag sollen als ich den
ersten teil vom adventskalender video
hochgeladen habe habe ich erst mal
nachgeschaut was dieser adventskalender
eigentlich kostet und es sind 70 euro
das macht ungefähr probier zwei euro 90
ist schon sehr teuer also falls ihr
nicht 92 pro bier ausgeben wollt könnt
ihr auch vielleicht ein bier laden gehen
und so ein adventskalender selber was
denn klar bioladen
man könnte ihn ist noch eine möglichkeit
huber kommt aus dänemark warum weiß ich
das war mein ex freund aus dänemark
kommt aber abgefüllt in deutschland von
carlsberg deutschland gmbh sie haben ein
ex freund aus dänemark war ganz nett
dass toborg hat eine dunkel goldige
farbe riecht gut schmeckt aber im
vergleich echt nicht so gut genau wie
mein exfreund hahahahaha lieber alkohol
gott bitte bleib bei mir nummer
das ist cool
seit 1854 ist beste zutaten gebraucht
nach nicht halt machen unsere pein
härtesten und bildung war einzigartig
ein wahrer genuss auf dem herzen der
natur es ist einzigartig dritten deutsch
ist hier war mal gucken wie einzigartig
jetzt wieder geschmack ist doch es hängt
wirklich erfrischend und leicht und hat
mich diesen starken ich bin den
biergeschmack ich glaube ich beck gerade
die skandale mich was das tour gehört in
die zu carlsberg und das hört auch
irgendwo zu carlsberg oder irgendwas das
ist das kunde aber so viele tiere
gehören zu irgendwelchen großen konzerne
und da können die mir doch nicht
erzählen dass es unterschiedliche biere
sind das sind doch einfach alles unter
unterschied label kommissar vanessa
ermittelt nummer zwei janko erstmal
nummer 19 warum fällt es mir bei diesem
bier adventskalender so schwer die
richtige reihenfolge zu kriegen
bei ausgeprägten hirnschäden in klammern
durch alkohol leiten konzentration
kurzzeitgedächtnis und merkfähigkeit uli
edel aus ein tschechisches tag lager und
dunkles bier
ich bin so aufgeregt erstklassiger
rohstoffen die art ethisches
brunnenwasser ausgesuchte gäste und saß
am goldenen horn bilden die grundlage
für das unverwechselbaren geschmack bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla mich heute das
ist ein richtiges schieben
ja man das wird nach schinken schmecken
hier haben wir wieder unseren
räucherschinken ja aber ganz ehrlich
tschechisches bier top eigentlich fast
nichts was verbirgt sich ein türchen
nummer 20 40 euro
okay das sieht aus also das logo sieht
aus als habe ich das selbst bei
photoshop sondern bastelt merten haben
berger photoshop philipp hat das gemacht
photoshop für keep on rockin philipp das
riecht ganz einzigartig dass
nörten-hardenberg schmeckt mir mega gut
das ist ein tolles bier einbecker
brauhaus ag falls du das siehst schenkt
mir doch mal an kassen
dieses bier ist fantastisch schmeckt
wirklich perfekt so heute bier schmecken
damit sich hier nummer eins darup rahmen
ein tschechisches bier das könnte jetzt
leider das nörten hardenberger aber
sowas von vom thron stoßen
startrang das glaube ich eigentlich
schon mein absolutes lieblings bier also
bis jetzt dachte ich das tolle goldene
farbe also wirklich wird dann gibt es
seit 8 ja es ist ein richtig gutes bier
aber das merten hamberger viel besser
mein gott ich finde das nürnberger kann
ich besser als starre bravo es tut mir
gerade so leider programm ist immer
meine erste liebe bleiben aber das
nörten hardenberg
das top nix 22 und ist wieder und es ist
eine schwere geburt
und das kommt aus thailand zeit für uns
schön weil es so die asiaten die machen
da elefanten rauchen löwen und blumen
und so rachel ingredients thailändisches
bier mit reis klargestellt ja auch
wieder so los ist dass asiaten hatten
einfach überall rein sehr hell
der duft ist perfekt den geschmack
enttäuschend es ist kein schlechtes bier
wenn ich in thailand wäre und das in
einem kiosk kaufen würde wäre ich habe
mit meinen wir aber ich würde es mir
niemals im später wieder greifen und
sagen oh ja stimmt es klang war so
lecker jetzt muss ich noch mal trinken
um mein gott nur noch zwei jahre dann
haben wir es geschafft
einer hat mir die kommentare geschrieben
dass man bei bier verkostungen das nicht
runterschlucken bei wein verkosten ich
dachte die sind von so einer
weinverkostung oder bierverkostung ist
halt dass man ein goldregen der spaß
wenn man alles wieder ausspuckt
tschechien am 23 das habe ich auch nie
markt tiger ein bier aus singapur so
dass kein reis drin sondern meist ich
mag ja die flaschen in asien die und
mexiko wir sind irgendwie ein bisschen
deutsche und tschechische diese
klassischen flaschen sind so einig es
ist irgendwie cooler es schmeckt in wiso
wie es erwartet hätte dort bin ich ja es
ist auf jeden fall lecker das schmeckt
wenn ich mal in singapur bin dann freue
ich mich drauf auf jeden fall original
tiger bier zu trinken okay es gebraut
und abgefüllt in der eu für diese firma
thing ist das finde ich gut weil ich
möchte eigentlich nicht so ein bier
trinken was halt extra aus singapur
jeher verschifft wurde ich bin froh wenn
es hier produziert wird es ist aber dann
ja irgendwie auch nicht so original ist
was ich meine
so leute und wir kommen nun endlich zum
allerletzten bieler danach haut mich
einfach wenn ich wieder auf die idee
komme so ein alkohol adventskalender
gleich mal so ein gen adventskalender 24
10 sorten probieren dann liegst und am
tisch das ist schon ein gutes ps sein er
oder sein weihnachtsbier das was man an
weihnachten trinkt muss doch das coolste
aller zeiten sein oh mein gott sie die
flasche cola aus bous komplex sri syed
will be global multi award winning bier
mädel ist premiumbier bluetooth reis
mais und tricks für das 24 türchen
einfach ein world beer dieses bier kommt
aus england also uk steht überall und
sie haben ein world beer gemacht
die flasche seht schon verdammt cool aus
als über also zum druck drauf okay ich
wollte jetzt hier so ein joke einbauen
von wegen
das ist ja kein druck sondern 1 0 und
ich habe es nach 20 minuten googeln
immer noch nicht hingekriegt
herauszufinden wieso eine wölbung auf
einer glasflasche heißt fünf minuten
später und mein gott ich hab's endlich
herausgefunden dass heißt prägung die
flasche wurde geprägt das bier wird
einfach besonders aus ich hoffe einfach
dass es jetzt das beste was ich jemals
getrunken haben er dürfte es perfekt
das design ist der hammer das ist ein
gutes bier ist hat auf jeden fall sein
cobra world beer global multi award
winning bradl ist verdient aber es
schmeckt mir zu komplex nicht oft genug
ich mag es oft wird aber ich glaube es
ist wirklich ein gutes bier und ist ein
schöner abschluss für das türchen nummer
24 ein welthit we are the world
[Musik]
ich glaube ich benutze das innere um
einen eigenen adventskalender zu basteln
total praktisch ja leute das war der bi
adventskaffee hoffen natürlich auch ich
hatte zwei detail gefallen und wenn ja
dann zeigt mir unbedingt ein daumen nach
oben es werden noch ganz viele
adventskalenders adventskalender
unboxing videos kommen also ein paar
sind noch geplant und ich hoffe ihr seid
fröhlich weiter ein
dieses programm das war die wendung für
heute wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal
wieder mit weniger alkohol dafür mit vor
ihr werdet es nicht glauben ich werde
euch auch nicht verraten aber es wird
diese woche auf jeden fall doch kommen
ich wünsche euch viel spaß dabei und wir
sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal
[Musik]